The year was 1835 when a young man named George Mueller
discovered that there were only about 12 orphan homes in all
of England and Wales.
And so he decided to act, he moved to Bristol.
And when he got to Bristol
after God had changed his life when he was in college,
he got to Brissell
and saw that for an orphan in that city, they had
to pay a fee to live in one of those group homes.
Or if they couldn't pay,
they were basically enslaved in a workhouse.
And so he and his wife sold all their possessions,
gave all the money to the poor,
and began praying for God to begin an orphan home
through their lives.
And God provided He began to bring orphans
because, 'cause George's desire was
that he wanted this place to be a place
that no orphan would be turned away
because of poverty or because of race.
He wanted them to be trained and educated for a trade.
And, and so God provided and began to bring orphans
and orphans and orphans to his door.
And God
provided just what they needed at just the right time.
Now, it didn't mean that it was always easy.
There were times whenever all the orphans would sit down
and the staff would sit down to eat with no food in front
of them and they would pray
and God would provide, whether it was a baker
who had a dream the night
before that he needed to bake an extra measure of bread
and bring it to him at the orphanage,
or whether it was a milk cart that broke down
outside the orphanage
and it would've spoiled if it wasn't used immediately.
God provided, it's estimated
that throughout his lifetime, Mueller gave away
what would be equivalent today of $129 million,
helping over 18,000 children in need.
The main British newspaper wrote at Mueller's death
that he had robbed the cruel streets of thousands
of victims, the jails of thousands of felons
and the workhouses of thousands of helpless waves.
Now, I, I realize that some people have started orphanages
by faith and they didn't succeed like this.
They might have even fallen apart or failed.
And I know that Mueller's pattern of praying
and not asking for money isn't the way we all have to do it.
He's not the universal principle here.
I start with his story
because of what was in his heart,
his desire to be generous with everything
God entrusted to him
to follow Christ's example that we see taught in Romans 1213
to contribute to the needs of the saints.
See, that's what we're doing this summer in this series
called realigned, is we are taking Christ's perfect standard
and we are realigning our lives by the Holy Spirit's power
back towards that we're not there
and we need to be realigned with Christ's life,
which includes in our generosity.
And here's why all this is so important,
because nearly more than anything else in our lives,
our view and use of money
reveals the true state of our hearts.
It reveals the idols that are actually in there.
Here's how Jesus said it.
Matthew six 19 through 21, he saiddo not lay up
for yourself treasures on earth where moth and rust destroy
and where thieves break in and steal.
But lay up for yourselves treasures in heaven
where neither moth nor rust destroys.
And where thieves do not break in
and steal for where your treasure is there,
your heart will be also.
And verse 24, he says, no one can serve two masters
for either he will hate the one and love the other,
or he will be devoted to the one and despise the other.
You cannot serve God and money.
I heard Tim Keller talk about this one time
that we could actually flip around verse 21
and say it this way, where your heart is
there, your treasure will follow where your heart is,
that's where your treasure will flow.
Meaning he asked this question, just think about this.
What is it effortless for to spend money on?
Like when you think about the way you spend money,
like what is just effortless?
It doesn't take any thought, no question.
You just spend it that reveals where your heart is,
where your heart is, your treasure will flow.
What that reveals where your heart, that reveal,
that reveals where your identity is found.
Because that's what you're looking for for me,
is travel new experiences.
Like I just can't wait to do something new
and see something new and experience something new that
that, that means I'm going to spend money
that it's effortless to to, for you it might be close.
It's not that for me, I got clothes
that are 20 years old, right?
But my identity is not found in the way I look or dress.
It might be for you. And so your, your budget shows
that the flowing of your treasure goes
to where your heart is.
Or it might be your kids that you're flowing that treasure
to them because your heart is like, I want to make sure
that they are secure and that's your idol.
Maybe, or,
or maybe it is something as simple as saving money, that
that's your, your idol of security
that you gotta make sure everything is secure for later
and you gotta make sure you're gonna control the future
so you have enough all and that's revealing your heart.
So here's the question today.
Is it effortless for you to give money to
the needy or to God's kingdom through his church?
Is it as effortless? Is it as normal?
Is it as easy for you to do that
and say, yes, take this here, give that.
Here's what you need. I'm gonna provide,
is it effortless for that?
If it's not, what does
that reveal about your heart, about
what you're treasuring in your life?
That's why I hope Romans 1213 moves the needle
for us a little bit today closer to what Jesus was quoted
as saying in, in Acts 2035, Jesus himself said, it is better
to give than to receive.
That's our goal today. So let's pray towards that end.
Lord, I I ask you by your spirit's power
to help us understand what you want us to understand
and see what you want us to see today.
And Lord, if it means that you're gonna lay a, a, a heavy
conviction on our souls, that we be ready
and receptive to that.
If it means you're gonna encourage us to do more of
what we're already doing, then Lord may we rest in that.
But we know we need to be aligned more towards you.
So help us Lord to see it And that you would reveal
where we don't treasure you enough.
We treasure other things more. Help us in Jesus' name.
Amen. So look now at Romans 1213
again, just the first part, phrase by phrase.
It's on you notes, it'll be on the screen as well.
It says contribute to the needs of the saints.
We're gonna see just three simple lessons from
this short phrase.
Here's the first. We learn
that every saint has needs at some point
based just on this phrase.
We learn every saint has needs at some point.
Now, if you're like me, you hear the word saint
and you think like the Roman Catholic stuff, right?
St. Thomas, St.
Luke stuff you've seen in stained glass
windows before, right?
Like you think these people
that in their tradition have been named saints,
that they've claimed lived a, a life of service to others,
that they have two verifiable miracles, one before they died
and one after they died.
That's how you get to be a saint in that tradition.
That's where our mind typically goes.
Now, separate from the many theological disagreements I have
with that, I'm really glad the Bible talks about
that word saint in a completely different way.
The way the Bible uses this word saint, is
that every believer is a saint.
'cause that word itself means one who is set apart, one
who is made holy, one who is made righteous
by something outside of you.
You are changed.
Now none of us can become a saint by what we do.
We are made holy.
We are made righteous by our faith in Jesus.
His blood washes us clean
and we are set apart for his purpose.
We are made into a saint.
Not said we're a saint by someone else. God makes us holy.
Now lemme just take a side note here.
Christian, never forget that
the enemy will tell you lie to you based on
what you've done, what you're struggling with now,
that you are not holy, you are not a saint.
You cannot get caught up in the lie.
The Bible says you are positionally before God.
Holy you are washed, clean,
acceptable before God.
Don't let the enemy lie to you.
Remember this truth, you are a saint by faith in Christ.
But we come back to Romans 1213.
What this means then is if we are to contribute to the needs
of the saints, that's referring to all followers of Christ,
contribute to the needs of every believer that we can.
Now we're assuming a couple things here.
Jesus did say that we are
to make sure our families are taken care of first.
That's a a minimum standard.
We don't need to make sure they're abundance, but,
but that they're taken care of, that they're provided for.
And Paul said if someone doesn't work, they shouldn't eat.
So if someone's able to work
and they're not, that's a problem.
So we're assuming those things,
but there will be times when Christians have genuine needs.
And so we are to care for them.
We are to contribute to those needs.
I i love the picture that Second Corinthians paints of this.
This is the apostle Paul, uh, in, in these two chapters,
second Corinthians eight and nine.
I'll encourage you to go read those later
today, the full part of that.
But in these chapters,
what he's doing is he's encouraging these
believers in all these churches around Asia.
He's saying, Hey, I'm, I'm collecting money
for the saints in Jerusalem who are really poor,
like extremely impoverished.
They really were about to die.
And so he's collecting money to try
to support them in Jerusalem.
Yet here's the thing, the churches, he's asking for help.
It's not like they were wealthy, they were poor too.
And yet these churches all over gave willingly
and abundantly to help those in need.
And it was about their hearts as they gave,
not about how much they could give.
It was about their hearts as they did it.
Because here's the thing, it could have been really
discouraging for someone who was only able
to give a couple pennies.
'cause there were wealthy Christians
that probably in those cities were like
able to give a lot more.
And they were just say, Hey man, take this to Jerusalem.
I I wanna love them, care for them.
And then this person over here can give two pennies and,
and you would think that would be discouraging to them.
But listen to two Corinthians eight verses 13 through 15,
how Paul addresses that.
He says, for I do not mean that others should be eased
and you burdened meaning you give more than you can.
And he's not asking you to do that.
He's saying as a matter of fairness,
your abundance at the present time should supply their need
so that their abundance may supply your need.
That there may be fairness as it is written.
Whoever gathered much had nothing left over.
Whoever gathered little had no lack.
He's talking about in Exodus the wilderness.
Whenever they were gathering the manna, it didn't matter
how much one gathered didn't gather in more
or less, they all ended up with the same.
It all evened out in the end. That's what he's saying here.
Some might have more now can give more now,
but other people might have more later can give more later.
And then at some point it's gonna be the other way around
that you have nothing and you need something from them.
That's the point he's making.
'cause the truth is that Christians are not immune
to financial struggle.
Just because you're a believer doesn't mean you won't go
through illness or hardship or anything like that.
Even really faithful Christians.
We're not saying here that just
because you're a believer you're gonna be wealthy.
Look at the early church, we look at them
as like they're the standards.
They were faithful. They were following Jesus as close
as you can and they were poor and persecuted.
The apostle Paul, as he goes in obedience on the mission
trips, God sent him.
He needed support from believers in order to make it happen.
So just because you have a lot now
doesn't mean you'll have a lot later.
There's no guarantee if you're trusting, listen, this is
so easy to do in our culture.
If you're trusting in a retirement plan or a savings account
or whatever it is, something
that you're trusting in other than the Lord
for your financial security, man that is a fickle foundation
because it can change like that and it can all go away.
And then where's your foundation?
This must be our foundation.
Our hope is in Christ our eternity.
Our security is in Christ.
And we might need, each of us might at some point need
even financially from others.
And so like Jesus did, we can
and should go about caring for people's physical needs.
Like Jesus fed the hungry, clothed, the naked.
He, he cared for the whole person. We should as well.
But let's just take this one step further.
If we broaden this out beyond just giving money,
just giving resources, there are
infinite needs all around us.
If we start doing that, If we start to say, well,
it's not just only about giving money, that's part of it.
But but what if? What if it's more?
And we as the body of Christ can meet those needs whether
it's relational connection for the lonely or
or whether it's emotional support for the hurting
spiritual leadership for those who are hopeless.
Mercy for those who feel outcast.
If we can see those needs as important too,
we can meet those as we look to give our lives
and, and listen, if I begin to see every believer
as a fellow saint, It shifts the giving
from superiority to inferiority, that kind of thing.
That dynamic of like, I'm gonna give you a handout
and I'm gonna help you try to come up to my level.
It shifts it away from that, that
and it starts to say, no, no, this is saint to saint.
This is family member to family member.
This is equal to equal.
We're just sharing as the family of God.
No one's better, no one's worse, none of that. It's equal.
We are all just saints together.
It changes the dynamic. Which
leads us to our second point today that giving
that we're talking about engages true Christian fellowship.
It is what facilitates, engages true Christian fellowship.
So look again at that first word in Romans 1213,
it's the word contribute.
Now, in the original language this was written in,
it's the word coin.
If you've been in church any length of time,
you probably recognize that word as similar
to the word koinonia, which means fellowship.
It means sharing. It means participation.
Now if you grew up in church, how many
of you had a fellowship hall in the church building
that you grew up going to?
Right? Anybody? Yeah, Uhhuh kinda look like this probably.
And what did we do in the fellowship hall?
Just ate food. That's all we did. That's it.
We would have, we would have fellowship meals
in the fellowship hall.
Now, I'm not saying that's wrong
because think about as you're eating a meal around a table,
you're sharing a meal, right?
So there's a sense of that.
But this word koinonia has so much more to it.
It's not just like handouts, charity giving money,
it carries with it the idea of family.
There's a connection here
where you are entering into the struggle with those
who need something in the moment.
Contribute Nia to those who are in need.
You're entering into it,
it's participating in each other's lives that yes,
we're giving to meet those needs,
but really that's just an indication
that something deeper is happening.
That our hearts are connected,
that we're actually walking in life together.
And I'm just gonna give to this need that you have
that's contributing.
That's fellowship.
Now this is my full-time vocation
and so I get time to study the landscape
of the church in America, read study, podcasts,
other things, just kinda look around and
and kind of identify what's going on.
And so when I look at things like this fellowship,
I see pockets it happening here.
Other churches, I see things like this going on
and I praise God for that.
But overall, churches in
America I think have missed it.
That we've lowered the standard.
See, if we're talking about fellowship like this,
if we're talking about true koinonia participation in life,
sharing needs, really living this out together,
if we're looking at what this is getting to
That is so much more than just
coming into a room for an hour every two
or three weeks sitting in rows
watching something happen and going home.
Right? This, this is, this is so much more than that.
There's so much more here.
What this word contribute was getting at it means true
fellowship is that your needs are my needs.
Your burdens are my burdens. My burdens are your burdens.
And we're sharing this together
and we're actually living out this life.
It's not just coming in and being consumers.
It's an investor in other people's lives
that when we contribute to needs like this, we are truly
devoted to one another.
We are actually creating bonds that
transcend every worldly barrier that the the
around us tries to put on us.
Like it shouldn't matter if you are
socially different or economically different
or ethnically different.
If you are a saint, your family,
if you're a saint by faith in Christ, you are family.
And here this, this is a little extreme to hear,
but if you are a saint, if we are family, that means you
and I or those Afghan believers, we are closer
together than you are with your unbelieving mom.
We are more connected than you are with your
unbelieving sister.
The blood of Christ flows deeper than biological blood
because we'll be with each other forever.
And the Holy Spirit unites us together.
That's this idea of fellowship
and the early church is a great picture of this.
Like we love Acts two.
We love how they lived out their faith,
this new radical way, powerful testimony to the gospel.
But what made it so compelling in part was
how different they were from each other.
And yet that was still happening
Because Remember the Pentecost is
where the church was birthed.
That was a feast
that people from all over the world had been brought
to Jerusalem to celebrate this
as the Jewish calendar dictated.
And so they were all there
and people from all kinds of
nationalities heard the gospel from Peter
and believed people
who may have been opposed to each other
before, were now living out things like Acts 2 44
through 47 that all who believed were together
and had all things in common
and they were selling their possessions and belongings
and distributing the proceeds to all as any had need.
And day by day attending the temple together,
breaking bread in their homes, they received their food
with glad, generous hearts, praising God,
having favor with all the people.
And the Lord added to their number day
by day those who were being saved.
Like that's true Christian fellowship.
They weren't unified merely
because they had the same economic class or
because they had similar habits in their lives or
because they were the same political party.
It was way bigger than that.
They were what Romans 12, five calls members one of another.
Why? Because of the gospel of Jesus Christ alone.
Because Jesus had changed their lives.
The Holy Spirit had filled them
and so they then contributed to one another in that pursuit
financially of course,
but then with time, with talent, with effort,
with resources, with skill, all of those things
that God had given them, they said, Hey, I'm gonna give this
to you as anyone has needs.
I'm gonna give it all. That's how we got
to our new value a few years ago of reimagined generosity.
This is a, a church value that that we see from this kind
of idea is that it is our privilege to get to use
what God has entrusted to each one of us, all
of these other things, to join him in
the care for his people.
You know, he uses us to care for his people.
He uses us to advance his kingdom in the world. He uses us.
What a privilege, what a gift that is to us that he gets
to do that through us.
Like what a gift.
Reimagining our generosity.
It's what first Timothy six teaches us,
Says, as for the rich in this present age, which by the way,
no matter how much you have
or don't have here in America, comparatively to the rest
of the world, we are rich.
So as for the rich in this present age, charge them not
to be haughty, prideful
nor to set their hopes on the uncertainty of riches,
but to set their hopes on God, who richly provides us
with everything to enjoy.
They are to do good, to be rich in good works,
to be generous and ready to share.
Thus storing up treasure for themselves as a good foundation
for the future so that they may take hold of
that which is truly life.
Truly life. See, we're talking about giving.
It's not an obligation.
Giving is an opportunity
to participate in God's work in the world.
We Don't have to.
We get to, and that is what
encourages fellowship in the deepest sense of the word
as we contribute to the needs of the saints.
Here's the thing though, it's not in our nature
to give, right?
We are naturally selfish people. We wanna hoard.
We want more and better stuff.
We wanna feel secure like I'm safe.
We want, we are selfish at our sinful nature.
That's why if we wanna get to that kind
of reimagined generosity, we have
to have a motivation better than guilt
because I could guilt trip you.
We could guilt trip you.
All of that could happen and it's gonna
last for a little bit.
But the true motivation of this kind of generosity is
what our third point says.
We give because of how God gives to us,
that's the motivation that will last.
We are generous people
because of
how generous our God is to us.
This command to contribute to the needs of the saints,
it flows from gospel grace.
See, we don't give to earn God's favor.
We already have God's favor in Christ.
We don't give to become saints in some way and
and do the works we give
because we already are saints in Christ
and we are filled with a generous God who gives us
what we can give to others.
It's giving out of the overflow of gratitude.
It's not trying to give more to try to overcome your guilt.
Like, man, I I, I really blew it again, I need to give more.
Like that's, that's wrong. That's not gospel.
This is giving in response to all that God has given us
in Christ And in the world.
Here's where we go back to two Corinthians eight
for some help in understanding this.
Again, remember, Paul's urging these believers
to give sacrificially.
He says this is his motivation two Corinthians eight, nine
for you know the grace of our Lord Jesus Christ,
that though he was rich, yet for your sake he became poor
so that you by his poverty might become rich.
That's the gospel, right?
He says Jesus had the richest of heaven,
everything about it,
and yet he set that aside to become poor like us so
that you and I could be rich with him forever.
Like that's how much he treasures you.
Don't forget this church like he treasures you that much
to say, I'm gonna set that aside
and I'm gonna go to live in the dust so I can be with them,
live for them, die for them, resurrect for them
and then they can be with me forever.
He did that for you. That's his love for you.
That's his treasuring of you.
Which then makes our giving in response fueled by
that gospel, which makes our giving then can be cheerful.
If that's what God had did for us,
then I can just cheerfully give
because of what he's done cheerfully for me.
When I give, I get to participate in what God did for me.
He gave cheerfully joyfully to me.
I get to experience a piece of that
as I give away to others.
See, when we think this way, that's
what makes it become less about percentages and minimums
and should it be gross or net, all these things.
It takes that conversation away
and it just means man, I get to share what God has
entrusted to me to steward.
Just get to share it. It doesn't matter
what I'm doing numbers wise, it's just like,
man, God gave me everything.
Here's, here's what I can give away.
It changes the conversation away from legalistic numbers
to just sharing
because God joyfully shared with us
and lemme be clear about something.
Everything I've talked about today has nothing to do
with how much money you have.
This is not just a conversation for those who are wealthy.
Everything about this, it's not about your abundance,
it's about God's abundance through you.
He owns the cattle on a thousand hills. He owns everything.
It's all his. Anyway, it's his abundance through you.
Just listen to this picture of of cheerful giver.
Again, Paul in second Corinthians was talking to people
who were poor and he's saying, give, give generously.
Listen to what he says.
This is Ians nine verses six through 15.
He says, the point is this,
whoever sow sparingly will also reap sparingly.
Whoever sows bountifully will also reap bountifully.
Each one must give as he has decided in his heart,
not reluctantly, not under compulsion.
For God loves a cheerful giver
and God is able to make all grace abound to you so
that having all sufficiency
and all things at all times you may abound in every good
work as it is written, he's distributed freely.
He's given to the poor. His righteousness endures forever.
Meaning he's given all of this to you. Watch this.
He who supplies seed to the sower bread for food will supply
and multiply your seed for sowing
and increase the harvest of your righteousness.
You will be enriched in every way, to be generous,
in every way, which
through us will produce thanksgiving to God.
Watch this. The ministry
of this servant is not only supplying the needs
of the saints but is also overflowing in many
Thanksgivings to God.
By their approval of this service, they,
the world will glorify God
because of your submission that comes from your confession,
the gospel of Jesus Christ
and the generosity of your contribution for them
and for all the others while they long for you
and pray for you because the surpassing grace
of God upon you, thanks be to God
for his inexpressible gift.
That is what the supernatural grace of God does in a heart.
It changes us from selfish motivations to
fruit of generosity that my life orients
away not to me.
It orients to others as I submit to the Lord,
as I trust the Lord with my future,
with his whatever I got this month.
Like, God, there's more month at the end of the paycheck,
but I'm gonna trust you.
I'm gonna be generous
'cause I know in this moment you're calling me to do that
and I'm gonna give to this person who's in need.
And you just say, gotta trust you. Watch what he does.
He works through you to provide for his people to
maybe even increase your ability to do that.
And it's all for his glory to spread through the world.
You remember what Jesus said, John 1335, he says, by this,
all people will know that you are my disciples.
If you have love for one another,
that doesn't mean affectionate
thoughts towards someone else.
That means genuine, sacrificial, generous love
for someone else where I'm entered into life with you.
I'm actually caring for you, supporting you when you need it
and you're doing the same for me.
That is the love he's talking about
and that is the love that the world has not seen very well
in churches in America.
Now, I'm thankful that
so many in our church give faithfully.
We have a benevolence fund that is overflowing.
That's how we care for people who are in need.
If you need that, don't feel ashamed to come ask for that.
We want to help as best we can.
We can't help everybody in the same
way, but we want to help.
We have money in that.
That is from giving people in our church.
We have ministries that are serving, caring
for people all over the place.
We have disciples being made. We're gonna camps.
We're doing all these things. VBS.
Now, people are being cared for through the fruit
of people generously giving through the church.
And we're blessed that we get to begin giving more away
to kingdom causes elsewhere as you and I give more.
But here's the reality.
Each of our hearts still needs some realignment.
'cause if we're honest, none of us are fully Christlike, yet
we still face the temptation to
treasure things in the world more than we treasure Christ.
We still face the temptation at times where we're not
as generous as we could be.
And so that's why over the last few months we have talked
about our focus being on delighting in Christ
Because guilt won't get us there.
Motivational speeches won't get us there.
Our focus has to be on Jesus
and what he has done for us.
That's the only way our hearts will actually change,
and that's the only way then the flow
of generosity will support the needs of the saints
around us, and that's the only way the world
around us will see
that our faith is not just about ourselves,
but it's about I care for you and I care for you
and you care for me, and we are a body together
as a community that starts by treasuring Christ more.
So I invite you to pray with me towards that end right now,
again, I don't know your situation, where you are,
what's going on in your heart,
what the Holy Spirit was impressing on you, but,
but I just want us to stop
and examine our hearts right now to just see
what we have been treasuring.
That is not what God would want us to treasure,
where we have prioritized things wrongly over him
where we have maybe,
maybe idolized something and,
and our heart is being revealed in that right now.
Listen, that's not a bad thing.
That is not something to run away from.
That's something to press into
because God is just loving you enough
to show you that right now.
He does that for me throughout the weeks as I prepare these
sermons and, and he's done that and he's doing that.
I believe in some of you right now,
and I pray, I pray God
that you lead us to see that there's a better way.
So maybe what you're seeing is like you just,
okay, I've never done this before.
I've never, never given anything.
And so it's just a baby step first.
Just start small, start regularly,
start trusting the Lord in a small way
and watch what he does with it.
Like, I don't think I can afford that.
Well just do you trust God?
It doesn't mean you give a whole lot.
You, you see what God wants you to give
and maybe it's just a little bit right now, a couple pennies
to go forward and, and just say, God, I want more.
I want to give more to you.
I want to release more in this Lord.
Or maybe you do have a lot and you are giving a lot
and you can see that God is just leading you to another step
of something that you release this selfish thing
so you can give more to God's kingdom purposes,
Whether it's to benevolence, to, to really make sure
that we can care even better for those in our church
who are struggling that they may not even know
or somebody in your CG that is really hurting right now
and you can say, man, let's, let's start
to support them a little bit more
for this season till they can get back on their feet
or give to support this church's ministry that,
that our heart is not to, to find more comforts for us,
more convenience for us,
but to expand the kingdom, to plant churches,
to send missionaries, to care for people in schools
that are impoverished, to support those in our city
who need more what?
That we wanna give more away.
Whatever the Lord's leading you to, we are gonna take a step
that we do every week of, of offering a time of giving
as worship here in a moment.
But that doesn't mean you have to, now there's online,
there's boxes at the doors.
You can send it by the mail.
There's all these things, but just make
a step, even a baby step.
Say, Jesus, I'm committing to you.
I want, I wanna reflect the gospel more
through this one specific way.
Lord, help us In Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen. I wanna invite you to stand as the ushers come.
We're gonna tab this time of giving as we sing,
but let's respond in faith to Him.